President Biden fell yesterday not just
a little stumble not just a little
tumble a full on Fall during the Air
Force Academy graduation
all the way down
not Chevy Chase doing Jerry Ford on SNL
all the way down has to be helped up by
three
three men
he points back at something on the floor
which is kind of funny it turns back he
says like oh is that it was that Pebbles
fault you know but it's it's ultimately
not funny it's sad and it's not even
news
that's why I had to play it
it's not really making news but it was a
bad fall and it's not news and that's
really weird it's not news because we've
come to expect it we've come to expect
it and we've come to accept it the
president is mentally and physically
falling apart